archives excess of all the former soviet
union fedos chick heavens opens up as and
filed a
backpack lloyd yes and run away
follow me hold on me the missing dolem
you valgasa them
mayor cars office iona skills I get
commandos
he still force awakens test life work
picker
esipov onyx
is possible
need
youtube
game is on
moto
jeep
and
glued
vince gear shift and
son behind the matchmakers
5 really very ambitious very
brave very such a crazy project
it was immediately clear that you are not
this film with a budget of 300 million
dollars we had the task of doing
something of our own
for each hero we were looking for an interesting
beautiful form of his appearance on the screen,
you would rather even go from this to a girl
who becomes invisible, or rather
translucent and
can interact with water;
there is an example at one point, the khan
swings
and at the other, the understudy, as it were, ends it
movement and, accordingly, the graphics, the
guys overwrote the understudies and they arose
when, in fact, well, he disappeared there
, did they distinguish stone and xiang xiang?
and
he's gay can control what stop when
we came up with philanthropy
but we thought that well yes it's cool
but when the first teasers began to appear there the
material on the Internet does not
catch cold everyone says only bears
despite the fact that my face will not be
in this bear it will be drawn
the character is named k and everything else, but the
plastic energy that we lay in
Ivan's
heroes, she will remain mine, drowning mentally
passed the
shutdown of plastic doors and
correspondence absolutely everywhere where we
see
I played him the actor himself, of
course, there is a lot of work on the schedule, it
takes a total of
more than a year and a lot  she is very
important every scene she
glare
we will see how the viewer perceives this, we will do our best so that the person
does not regret that he came to the
cinema for two hours he
will not be bored.
defenders is the first Russian film
about a superhero, so we developed
this whole story from scratch, we don’t have, so to speak,
in the mentality of the culture of comics, so
we had nothing to base ourselves on, we
came up with our own philosophy and
this is what really helps us to
differ from Western analogues
our film right away  gets a lot of bonuses
because it's not much of a fairy tale a
fantastic fairy tale with
action elements and here to watch these
ups and downs in which the heroes are
how they save no I would say this
film is generally one big attraction
we really don't want a large
degree of freedom and really very
large resources  and everything came together so the
price will come out with a really interesting
visual plan, which, not only on the
scale of Russia, and again, with
colossal abundant computer
graphics, we try to bring
real ones to me, like that, in
principle, it also inspires and helps to make
movies realistically people want to see
superhumans if it is so far  to tell credibly
and convincingly if you explain why this
person is like this why he has the
ability to me how he pays
for this shackle mechanism how exactly weaknesses
if you do it right it should
attract already the time has come when
generations
water generations next generations they
need something of their own through protectors
can  to convey to the little depends
a lot of interest in things, but who already
understands himself we do not compete with
marvel products and from biosea products
we just make a good movie within
our budget and within our country
in two weeks I have to travel around the entire
former Soviet Union to assemble a team of
superhumans  and stop over people the
corpse saluting these people is our only
hope what is the name of the defenders on the Yenisei
we are the same as you I want to know who
did this to you come with us the
rapid offensive of the armada of military
forces on the capital continues the
army in the field was powerless before the onslaught of the
enemy all attempts  osta  new
offensive end with the failure of all
military equipment
I have been waiting for this for half a century there is no way back
our experimental development department has
prepared special suits that increase your
efficiency and
squeeze it out